[Musik]
mehr
ja ich stehe hier mit traum jetzt von
der deutschen umwelthilfe westenberger
von der bürgerschaft fraktion der cdu
hamburg
ich wollte jemanden dabei haben der auch
politisch etwas bewegen kann aber leider
hatte von vw niemand zeit das nicht so
dass sie diese problematik derzeit der
politik keine rolle spielen das ist ja
nicht so dass liegt durchaus auch daran
dass wir eben auch geltende vorschriften
haben und versuchen die
automobilindustrie zu schützen und diese
geltende vorschriften haben versuchen
die umzusetzen und sie auch einer die
und sie auch ihrer geltung so oder so
dass sie ihrer geltung auch die
notwendige kraft verleihen
deswegen brauchen wir die zone deswegen
auch mit die pflegearbeiten wir wohl bis
vier positionen setzen bist bist du die
statistisch bis zum nordpol und dann bis
ins mittelmeer mittelmeer bereich wo
wollen sie grenzen ziehen seit 2010
geltende grenzwerte das sind jetzt acht
jahre man hätte er zeit gehabt innerhalb
dieser acht jahre was zu entwickeln der
menschen zu erklären was man jetzt zu
tun gedenkt um ihre gesundheit zu
schützen also das wird der gesetzgeber
machen wann denn
das war ein schöner moment wo sie was
wir wollen sind die sauberen fahrzeuge
und es beginnt nicht die schilder des
problems in die fahrzeuge die nicht
sauber sind das problem sind die
fahrzeuge nicht sauber sein der
walfanggegner den müllwagen an der ist
nicht sauber
nehmen wir die busfahrerin ist dem
gericht man januar weil er haut ja auch
abgase raus da hinten kommt der nächste
bus der zwischen 60 und 80 liter auf 100
kilometer verbraucht in der stadt daran
merken sie doch schon es geht nicht ohne
kompakte lösung aber irgendwo muss man
doch mit den lösungen anja wille zum
fahren wir zum verfahren ich finde auf
jeden fall schön dass sie dieses
gespräch fast komplett alleine führen
weil ich möchte hier so wenig wie
möglich atmen allerdings recht es geht
mir genauso deswegen man sollte sich
möglichst schnell wieder vom acker
machen wenn man an solchen straßen steht
ich atme unglaublich gerne und ich freue
mich auf weitere gespräche
ca
[Musik]
wie sinnvoll sind diese fahrverbote ja
natürlich sonderlich sinnvoll weil man
eigentlich diesen gesamten
schiffsverkehr der hier auch im
hamburger hafen ist 80 fertig rauslässt
ein großes kreuzfahrtschiff stößt am tag
etwa so viel stickoxid emissionen aus
wie 400.000 pkw der wind kommt hier aus
südwest im regelfall und wird nach
nordost und da ist die stadt und
insofern kann man sich dem eigentlich
echt schlecht entziehen wenn man vor
allem zusätzlich noch den straßenverkehr
also die hamburger sind so oder so am
arsch wenn man das so klappt sich
formulieren wir sind sie aber das muss
man da so sagen
wie finden sie die luft hier in hamburg
also im moment richtig notiz
was halten sie von den diesel
fahrverboten mix muss alles verboten
sein oder gar nicht stimmt was wäre ihre
lösung
eine lösung wäre alles autos abschaffen
deswegen haben jetzt die möglichkeit mir
ihren schlüssel zu geben ja und dann wer
ein auto weniger schon mal ja ok aber
muss sie abgeben
wenn dann alles tun würden würde ich das
auch tun sie können den anfang machen
der anfang einer bewegung sein
das stimmt sie haben ihr recht also das
ist doch schon mal ein positives zeichen
und mit diesen guten nachrichten gebe
ich zurück ins studio
[Applaus]